all right so good afternoon everyone
hi and welcome my name is Quan Tran and
I'm a lecturer here in the ethnicity
race and migration program it was the
American Studies Program it is my
pleasure to welcome you today to today's
discussion panel on the topic of
asian-american in the 21st century and
this event is part of the Asian American
Studies speakers series that is
organized by the Center for the Study of
race indigeneity and transnational
migration co-sponsored by the
asian-american Cultural Center and the
American Studies Program and before we
start I just wanted to give a quick
thing to steve pity from aaron johnson
Nandi Cummings Joanna the Julianne
ji-dan who sang and Mary Lou Alda behind
a scene work that they've done in order
to make this panel a reality and also to
our panelists for agreeing to come and
just a quick note because of the
historical sort of moments that we have
these speakers here this event is being
videotaped for posterity but also for
those who are interested but it might
not be able to make it here today so I
am very excited and honored to welcome
our distinguished guests to in and to
introduce them as well as the panel a
month shy of 50 years ago black student
the Black Student Union and the third
world Liberation Front in San Francisco
State College began one of the most
historic student strikes to demand for
campus reform and the creation of Black
Studies as well as ethnic studies
program and because of their work their
intellectual and emotional labor those
students and their allies have given us
the birth of Black Studies Asian
American Studies Chicano Studies and
Native American Studies and it's only
fitting that upon the 50th anniversary
of that strike we have here today with
us three distinguished and prominent
scholars in the field of Asian American
Studies professor Lisa Lowe professor
Kathleen vile and
karaoke hero they're here to share with
us their thoughts on the past present
but also future directions of
asian-american studies of the field and
joining them is Professor Daniel
Martinez Jose who is a faculty here on
yo campus teaching an ethnicity race and
migration and American Studies so on
their own merits but also together these
three alysha's scholars here have really
made tremendous intellectual
contributions to the field of
asian-american Studies as well other
academic fields that are related and
their work have been foundational and
generative for many of us and some of us
in this room and myself included are
indebted to their intellectual labor but
also to their incredibly generous
mentorship and between the three of them
they have mentored and taught many many
students who've gone on to contribute
further into the field of asian-american
Studies so professor Lisa Lo is
distinguished professor of English and
humanities and director of the Center
for the Humanities at Tufts University
where she is also a faculty member of
the consortium of studies race
colonialism and diaspora however in 2019
January
she will be a part of Yale faculty
so join us this is Samuel Knight
professor of American Studies so along
with her numerous articles for most
recent publications include and I was
trying actually to figure out you know
do I name all the work that they have
done and that would take us into the
entirety of this talk so I was just
named the most recent three works that
they have published and professor Lowe
has published the intimacy's the four
continent the politics of culture in the
shadow of capital and immigrant acts on
Asian American cultural politics and
next to Professor LOH is professor
Kathleen vials who is currently
professor of English and Asian Asian
American Studies and associate dean for
humanities and diversity equity and
inclusion at the University of
Connecticut its stores
she's also the current president of the
Association for Asian American Studies
not anymore
return to ending my term just in her
recent publications include redrawing
the historical past history memory and
multi-ethnic graphic now narrative Asian
America a primary source reader and
flashpoints for Asian American Studies
and last but not least we have professor
Gary Akihiro who is visiting professor
and ethnicity race and migration at Yale
he joins us from Columbia University
where he is professor of International
and public affairs and the founding
director of the Center for the Study of
ethnic ethnicity and race and yeah he
teaches courses in intro to third world
studies and fruits of empire this
semester
professor okie Hiro also served as the
president of the Association for Asian
American Studies between 1985 and 1987
his most recent publications include
third-world studies the rising
liberation American Studies unbound
Asian and Pacific Islanders and
pineapple culture or history of the
tropical and temperate zones so without
further ado could you please give a
welcome to our customers hi everybody
welcome thanks so much for coming I'm
gonna start out just orient us a little
bit and then post some questions to kind
of get the discussion started but I just
want to thank and acknowledge our
colleagues from the asian-american
cultural center here it's amazing to
think we have in this room like four or
five faculty now spread across a number
of units or doing work in Asian American
Studies so it's a really exciting time
and I one story I wanted to share you
know it's just part two think think this
through is I was actually an
undergraduate at Wesleyan some time ago
and invited Gary when he was at Cornell
to give a talk in Asian American Studies
we were trying to get one course offered
in Asian American Studies and I think I
wrote him a letter he responded and he
came down and he gave this wonderful
wide-ranging talk like a beautiful
discussion afterward and at some point I
stepped in and you know said can we now
talk about like how are we
institutionalize Asian American Studies
here and Gary kind of gave me this look
like you know we had this really good
discussion going and now you know you're
gonna like bog us down you know with
these questions I'm part of what I like
thinking back took is like we can be
doing Asian American Studies thinking
through its logics its optics and
commence commitments even in the absence
of something that the institution
recognizes as a program in Asian
American Studies and I think that's part
of what's our point of departure is
today is thinking about what Asian
American Studies can all the insights
and the space it opens up for us even
even for those of us that may not
identify kind of directly with the field
and so we're gonna do this I'm going to
just kind of pose a series of two
questions that I'll invite each of them
to talk about for a little bit and then
a third question that's actually
tailored a little bit more around their
work and that should take us 30 minutes
or so and then we'll open it up and
really welcome and invite your questions
okay so the first question is about
point of entry and given
both not your like distinguished
contributions and kind of presence in
the field but also that different
moments at which you entered or came to
inhabit Asian American Studies and we're
gonna start with Gary can you talk about
how your scholarship first led you to
Asian American Studies what did the
field its literature its theories its
commitments its politics
allow your work to do what kinds of
questions did it help you answer I think
that's why I'm starting the discussion
I'm the oldest person on this panel here
possibly in the room actually
and when I started in Asian American
there was nothing there was no Asian
American Studies all right I mean the
literature was not what I would call
Asian American literature we learned
from one another my point of entry was
from African history I began my graduate
career in African history and I was so
taken by the fields two points of entry
at that point that I'm talking about
African history which was new at the
time also I'm talking about 1967 in the
u.s. anyway it was new one was the idea
of Afro centrosome not the only FEA
Sante variety Molefi and I were graduate
students together actually and we
learned about Alpha centrism in African
history there which was a recovery of
African history as opposed to the deeds
of Europeans in Africa which was
Imperial history so that recovery was an
exciting time for African us to try to
recover an African past from their
African point of view that was one the
other was what one of my professors
began was terrence ranger resistance the
idea of resistance
those two key ideas I think was what I
took or I um led me to the study of
Asian American as I said there was no
field when I first entered I was among
the first graduate cohort graduate
students who began to study Asian
American Studies at UCLA and that was
led by a graduate of Yale Don nakanishi
and we had that seminar on
asian-americans at UCLA and there are
only three of us in that seminar
I guess the entry into Asian American
Studies was um because of my um desire
to learn about myself which is an entry
very common to most of us in Asian
American Studies I think indeed in all
ethnic studies but also to bring what I
learned from African history into Asian
American Studies and thus I began to
study an Asian American study resistance
the idea of resistance and trying to
articulate the voices of Asian Americans
from their point of view
Kathy you okay um I I first want to
thank Wan and Dan for just making this
wonderfulness happen I also want to
thank each of you for getting me out of
stores Connecticut I always like to
leave the quiet corner we always stress
that we are in the middle we're actually
in the middle of somewhere so it's nice
to be somewhere that is in the middle of
a real place so thank you so much um so
I am admittedly humbled and I feel
awkward for those of you who know me I'm
I'm a very socially mallet or human
being so this awkwardness is not it's
not something that is unexpected but
actually in and I will get to this in
some ways like my point of entry into
the field intellectually was facilitated
afar at the University of Massachusetts
by the work of Gary and Lisa in
particular margins and main streams and
immigrant acts but in terms of the first
question that Dan posed I actually began
my graduate career not as an
asian-american is not as somebody in
ethnic Americans that are thickened
literature or ethnic studies but
actually a Victorian astiz unbelievable
and unimaginable but I was and I'm I'm
being a bit confessional I I was into
Victorian literature because I had spent
eight years on a military base in
England Lakenheath England so when I
actually came to the United States I had
this awful British accent which did not
go over very well in Valdosta Georgia so
but I was always very nostalgic for that
time because like because of the order
of the military base was right before my
father my adoptive father retired so I
was really drawn to British literature
and when I went to the University of
Texas there was no such thing as Asian
American Studies and to put it into
context in my four years there I had
exactly two female
professors and that was it so and I went
to school there in the 1990s not the
1890s so so that kind of provides a bit
of context into why I might not have
pursued asian-american studies and then
when I came to the University of
Massachusetts I you know with the intent
to study Victorian literature my focus
was actually going to be on the
syphilitic subject and it's not that I
have syphilis not that although it could
happen right that I don't want a
foreclosed possibility here but but I
was really interested in the ways in
which race was actually negotiated
through the civil it've subject that was
like the closest thing that I could get
to in terms of a racialized figure and
when I shared this with my would-be
advisor he perhaps responding to the
syphilis said well I don't think that's
a very good idea at all and it just so
happened that one of the requirements I
had at my university and my graduate
program was to take an ethnic studies
course and I happen to take a course
with su-9 Amira in the very brief time
that she was at the University of
Massachusetts right so it was like
capturing a comet and I was so lucky to
work with her and she taught an Asian
American Studies class which is where I
encountered Lisa and Gary's work right
and as somebody east of California is
somebody who did not have the luxury of
an institutionalized program right it
was really from afar that I got to know
the field right so I've talked about
like kind of the intellectual entry
point but the personal entry point is
one that I've struggled with for much
longer time so because I'm very
self-absorbed I'll actually close with
personal stories so I am you know
and that's why I'm a Dean right
associate dean right I it the power
right so I'm so myself absorb rightly so
but when I when I was about to go to
graduate school I had always known that
I was adopted right and I was born in
Thailand and that's really all I knew so
when I was talking to my father at the
airport I was just joking that the only
movie for Thai people was the King and I
and how sad I was about that and he had
actually said no your film is the
killing field and that was quite
shocking because I had absolutely no
idea what that meant I had known about
the Cambodian genocide quite you know
superficially and it actually prompted
me to kind of explore that particular
history and that particular connection
knowing full well that I did not have it
and what I mean by that is that when I
was adopted I was I was born in 1974
right outside of Royal Thai food or an
Air Force Base which happened to be the
headquarters of the air America fleet
which is the CIA own fleet so you may
not know that fleet but how many of you
have seen images of the quote fall of
Saigon and the black helicopters
those are Air America helicopters and it
was from that particular base that
munitions runs and drug runs were done
over Laos and into Laos but I also had
the designation of being the site for
scare air and what the CIA would do is
actually put various flags of countries
that planes would fly over so that it
was easier to bomb undetected right so I
was born on this Air Force Base the
product of a Cambodian mother and a u.s.
GI my brother and I we I have a twin and
it just so happened on that on that base
my adoptive father
another American GI and my Japanese
mother were there and they had spent 13
years of their marriage looking for
children and I had no idea about my
mother's
has but I found out much later that my
mother who's Japanese lived 20 miles
outside of Nagasaki when the bomb was
dropped and she was 11 years old and
none of the women and her family could
have children so it just so happened
that you know because of war we were all
brought together and it was because of
war that I started this pursuit into
well what exactly does remembrance mean
when you have absolutely no memory of a
traumatic event so um so that's actually
what led to like my second monograph war
genocide injustice on Cambodian American
memory work but it actually took me
years to come up with that because I did
not have like the you know like the same
entry point that Gary had by way of
African history and it was a very
difficult history to put together
because I had no mentors right so I
actually relied heavily on Gary's like
chapter when and where I enter to remind
me how I was situated in the field and
also Lisa's notion of a tireless
reckoning with the past which I
constantly referred to so with that I'll
just close but thank you so much I'd
like to thank Dan and Quan also and
Alicia and Steve and Mary it's really
wonderful to be here with Gary and Kathy
to close and admired friends and
colleagues so I'm gonna since Kathy's
talked about herself
I think John talked about myself too
maybe because I think there's a way in
which in race and ethnic studies there
is this idea that it's not history I
mean I think that that's an
oversimplified reduction that is a way
of trivializing and dismissing something
quite serious which is that each of us
have a history that is embedded in
different conditions that are largely
documented within national history and I
think the corollary of that is each of
our stories of coming into the
University and not having any history
that addresses our pasts so I grew up in
Los Angeles as a chinese-american and my
parents came to the u.s. in 1945 they
were refugees from the Japanese bombing
of China and and stayed after the
Chinese Revolution in 1949 and I studied
European history and French and
comparative literature and didn't find
in those fields the history that
explained how my family and how I came
to be an American I have an anecdote
like the when Dan told about Gary when I
was my first job where I was for a
number of decades was at the University
of California San Diego and we didn't
have ethnic studies at that time in the
1980s and we thought we'll we'll have
[Music]
Gary come and michael.lowe me come and
Elaine camp where our three and
eventually we worked and and UCSD has
now a comparative ethnic studies which
was the the way in which we chose to
institutionalize it which I think has
resonance with ER NM here and of course
Steve and ELISA have UC San Diego pasts
as well but so the simple answer how I
started I was first led to Asian
American Studies was that I I taught at
a university where there was no Asian
American curriculum and I wasn't trained
in Asian American City so I started to
read Gary and sue Chang Chen and Ron
Takaki and taught myself about Asian
American history and started teaching
Asian American Studies and then
eventually wrote immigrant acts I
learned a lot from my students as well
as the larger context of living in the
you know in
California as an asian-american the more
complicated answer is that I think the
case of asian-americans this history of
being non-citizens for nearly a century
contributing to the economic development
of the United States building the
Transcontinental railroads building
American capitalism but being barred
from citizenship for nearly a century is
a fascinating case study that resonates
with other immigrant Americans it
resonates but is not equivalent to
enslaved black Africans but it has a
great deal to tell us about the history
of the United States the history of
citizenship capitalism and empire from
the perspective of the case of Asian
immigrants and Asian Americans and it
tells us a great deal about how race and
racial formation are central to
citizenship capitalism and Empire not
only in the past but today and ever
evermore we need only we can rant
afterwards but I wouldn't mean to being
in comparative literature I was
especially interested also in the role
of culture and particularly in the case
of Asian Americans if you are barred
from citizenship you're barred from
belonging and participation in the state
and then political culture but also in
national culture as well so what does
that mean about the letters the stories
the films that music the ways of living
congregating building towns what does
that say about Asian American culture if
it's if it's barred from the national
participation so that interested me I
also think now I think the question is
what kinds of questions did it help you
answer it seems to me that Asian
immigration is central to the
understanding of what capitalism is I
mean if you think about just the Asian
American case of the necessity of
disenfranchised non citizen labor that's
racialized
other that's barred from citizenship in
order to extract labor to build modern
industrial capitalism it tells us a lot
about the way capitalism needs to
differentiate through race and it also
tells us a lot if you think about the
laws in which for example the page law
that for forbade or prohibited further
late 19th century female immigration
from China because it was male labor was
selected for particular kinds of
purposes and you wouldn't have a
reproductive family society and
community if you had women as well that
tells us something about how capitalism
works and it tells us something about
how race and gender and class are
imbricated with for another Ness at the
convenience of a particular moment
moment of industrial capitalism so I
don't want to start getting too
elaborate but I just want to say that
that there's a way in which you could
tell a history of US capitalism through
looking at asian-americans just as you
can tell a history of US capitalism by
looking at African American slavery so
that's that's what kinds of questions
that helps me answer but I also think
Asian Americans are an index and
illustration of US imperial interests in
East Asia and the Pacific Islands
Filipinos Koreans Vietnamese Cambodians
and Pacific Islanders are in the United
States as Kathy's description of her own
autobiography tells us because of US war
and militarism in East and Southeast
Asia and the Pacific so in this way I
think of we can talk more about this I
think that my colleagues agree that
Asian American Studies isn't just me
story of course it involves our stories
we are situated historical subjects
whose who are inscribed by our
historical condition
but it's a global comparative relation
study challenge to situate the racial
formation of Asian immigrants in the US
within this longer history of
colonialism global migration and Empire
writing these now that's so wonderful
and generative and you know just these
responses made me think about this
twinning of both absences which we hear
throughout the absences and programs the
absences and kind of analytics and in
histories but also articulations that
the point of those absences wasn't to
kind of build some fortified field that
wouldn't be engaged with all of these
other questions but in fact would find
roots to them so the second question
we're gonna ask you to reflect on is
your sense of the field today however
you want to kind of find your way to
that both what you find generative
helpful and productive and where you
might see some challenges and
limitations so situate your your this
work for us in relation to contemporary
scholarship I would like to continue on
Lisa's discussion because well you know
I'm so thrilled about this just sitting
on this panel at least that we haven't
seen each other for years and decades
several decades ago when I had an
opportunity to begin a program at the
University of Washington I thought about
the dream team that I would have there
in Asian American Studies that was
before you can't be so I included Lisa
and Michael owe me and I'm so thrilled
that her office is right across my
office now here at Yale so an amazing
thing at the end of our career not Mike
to finally come together Thank You
Alisha but anyway um let's see now okay
when I gave a talk and UC Berkeley which
was the one of the hubs in the Bay Area
for the third world Liberation Front the
movement 68-69
one of the faculty and ethnic studies at
that institution asked me after my
presentation about islands and
continents it's from the book island
world she was the first one to ask me
this question she said what does that
have to do with Asian American Studies
what does islands and continents have to
do with Asian American Studies I thought
coming from this senior person one of
the founders of our field I think
instead of a broadening many of us in
the field have narrowed our point of
view and I think that the excitement of
the future of the field is to destroy to
destroy you have field of which I was a
founder I think it needs to be destroyed
and we need to move beyond those
founding propositions exactly what Lisa
was talking about here in terms of
capitalism imperialism all these other
categories that are not sort of confined
to our racial formation with which I
began I think we were correct in that
Asian American Studies African American
Studies lot next Studies was liberating
it was liberating there's no doubt about
it we had to speak and be heard and our
voices were as important as everyone
else's but I think that turn to national
culture is fun all wrote very
beautifully in the wretched of the earth
and is a kind of founding document for
all of us in these
yields called ethnic studies while it
was entirely liberating at the moment I
think we need to get beyond that now now
what I'm saying is this that at least
this what I'm teaching in my course
there will studies any students here
anyway okay like the name of the field
ethnic studies is a misnomer the
students demanded third world studies
that's what they demanded and they
demanded a third world curriculum
because they did not identify with
nation states or nationalisms they
identified with a global revolution
what Dubois called the problem of the
20th century colonialism and racism the
ideology that supported the material
relations they demanded third well
studies the faculty and administrators
acquiesced in giving them ethnic studies
ethnic studies was named by the chicago
school of sociology and ethnic studies
was designed to contain to assimilate
immigrants into American life that was
totally the opposite of what those
students demanded they identified with
the third world people of color who were
colonized the formerly colonized
colonized and they saw their movement as
transformative as revolutionary like
transforming over 400 years of world
history they weren't there to reform the
curriculum insert little things about
ethnic people in the United States they
were part of this global revolution
against colonialism imperialism that's
what they were after we the faculty
acquiesced in this notion about the
nation-state as the unit of our analysis
about race relations and race for racial
formation within that nation-state as
indicative of our plight and so forth
we're not after civil rights they were
after human rights they were after
nationalism they were after this global
shock so I think the excitement in the
field is the kind of work that Lisa and
Kathy are doing in destabilizing those
original founding categories I think we
need to move I'm I'm saying wait first
of all it is important that is the field
of study is important it is important we
need to do Asian American history like
Professor Liu is teaching today I think
that's important but I think we are also
important to keep our eyes on the prize
they prize is not sort of self-recovery
it is about a global revolution it is
not about one little group of people it
is about the human condition broadly how
many social side our human sciences
study a racialized group designated by
Europeans and we sort of subscribe to
those categories that taxonomy which was
designed to colonize yeah anyway
[Laughter]
we study that is those in third well
studies study the human condition
broadly we're not little things we added
stab down my textbook called
American history unbound was forced on
me by the publishers University of
California Press said you cannot write
American history no I claim American
history and I'm writing American history
from this point of view this position
and that's as authentic as a European
man who writes American history and
titles at American history no they said
you've got to modify that so unbound who
has show
but I wanted unbound in really tiny
letters so nobody could read it and
predictably they printed it in red
you know unbound all right okay
but anyway I think that's the excitement
in the field that is that we're
exceeding the bounds of the original
founders and that's the excitement yeah
[Laughter]
so I'm going to certainly disappoint
thank you but I actually want to build
on what Lisa put forth in terms of
capitalism and imperialism and kind of I
hate to use this term especially with
somebody I respect but I'm going to say
it is just I want to piggyback on what
Garrett I just hate that word RIF right
like on on Gary's point and kind of take
it in different directions so you know
one of the things that it was really
striking being the president of the
Association for Asian American Studies
was the extent to which in many ways the
question of institutionalization had
been answered
right so the very fact that we had a
robust membership the fact that there
were faculty not only on the coast but
in the Midwest and everywhere else
really kind of highlighted a legibility
for the field that was actually
confirmed in Tina Chen recently observed
this in an American literature article
was confirmed by the publication of a
number of anthologies you know I had a
co-edited with Linda faux and Scott Wong
keywords for Asian American Studies
Cambridge put out two collections
focused on Asian American literature
Ravich also did the equivalent of a
keywords Siri like publication with
Rachel Lee so in some ways like if we
were looking for institutional you know
like institutional confirmation we
actually had it as Asian American s but
I think that what's most exciting is
that that conversation about
institutional is
nation has given way to a much more
robust conversation a much more critical
conversation about the relevance of
Asian American Studies particularly in
this present moment and I think that you
know the idea of Asian American Studies
offering unique and critical look at
capitalism and imperialism is very well
taken it highlights the relevance and I
also know that Lisa's work has engaged
entanglements particularly trans-pacific
entanglements and militarization so it's
that question of relevance as a key word
is one that I go back to and it does
come back and it also goes to those
third world Liberation Front movements
and the idea that students did not just
want a course of study that would teach
them what it meant to be Asian American
they wanted an education that's relevant
right and it's that relevance that to me
is most tricky when one talks about the
institutionalization of Asian American
Studies in higher ed and this is where
I'm part of the institution and then I'm
apart from it so what I mean by that is
that you know I am actually drawn to the
fact that ethnic studies is in many ways
from the outset a co-opted and like kind
of defamed articulation of what was the
original purpose and you know I am drawn
by rod Ferguson's argument that once
something is institutionalized then its
politics become a bit suspect and if one
thinks about the formation of ethnic
studies I have argued that one must
necessarily think about planned
obsolescence so the very basis of
funding the the struggles right the fact
that these calls for hires occur with a
population that the administration will
temporarily listen to you and then just
wait for you to graduate the the the
focus on joint appointments as to
full-time appointments the emphasis that
you know because we live in a
multicultural paradise ethnic studies is
no longer necessary all points to the
fact that within a multicultural
neoliberal university imaginary ethnic
studies is always going to be irrelevant
right it's going to be strategically
deployed but the question is always will
it be tactically sustained right and
this is something that I've witnessed
firsthand right so one one way to think
about this and one of the questions that
the field must ask itself constantly in
terms of relevance is what like what is
the relevance of Asian American Studies
at an institution where Asian Americans
are considered model minorities in a
state of Connecticut where Asian
Americans are not even considered a
minority population right and they are
constantly being pitted against other
ethnic studies enclaves at an
institution right on the one hand one
could say that we are all in solidarity
and that we advocate for each other but
on the other hand I think the Asian
American Studies because of engagements
with probationary whiteness is in a
unique position of discussing and
contemplating complicity so and this is
actually one of the more compelling you
know kind of keywords that I've
encountered is the notion of the
complicit so it's one thing for example
for us to all claim Yuri Kochiyama
it is another thing for us to all look
at I'm not going to mention the person
at Yale but like like if we look at
somebody like Dinesh D'Souza right or
it's one thing to celebrate crazy rich
Asians but it's another thing to think
about how that is a film that really you
know kind of makes heroic the neoliberal
Asian subject and last but certainly not
least the question that I always return
to us why is it that Asian Americans who
experience discrimination racial
who are at the forefront of like
immigration debates are always the last
to be asked to opine on what's happening
in this country right so those are the
questions that I think that the field
has to you know kind of grapple with
because for so long it was part of this
ethnic studies like kind of iterative
list and now I think the more
interesting question is what does Asian
American Studies say about white
supremacy when we have individuals like
Peter Liang in our midst right like what
can we do like it or the fact that Asian
Americans were named in Dylann roofs
letter well as a as a population that
was worthy of supremacist attention
right and not in a bad way right so um
I'll just conclude with that I mean I I
can be a lot more positive but but I
think that like Gary really set the tone
for me so well you guys have said some
very interesting let me let me try to
tell you about how I'm thinking about it
I think one of the ways since we've
talked about institutionalization and
the exploding of former categories I
mean I think we might think about this
in terms of whether the study of Asian
Americans is additive to a national
story or if it aspires to be
incorporated as a an example an
exceptional example in that story or if
we think about Asian American Studies as
I was trying to describe it earlier as
really a lever to open up a set of
critiques that are really aimed at not
just questioning knowledge formation but
also aimed at social transformation in
some way and I think that's the real
potential of
in American Studies and also its
challenge it's a challenge and
opportunity I think there's a challenge
too for example see the links that not
the equivalences but the links between
Asian immigrant labor and African
American slavery to see the links
between Asians coming from sites in
which the US waged war throughout the
20th century and the links with Arab
Muslim and South Asian immigrants to the
US to see the story of Asian Americans
as an example of how US interests in
other places is linked to the
disenfranchisement of those subjects
when they come here that that connects
with a lot of different subjects and
areas but also I think they're one of
the challenges is to again as I said to
have it be the interrogation of a kind
of American Exceptionalist repertoire or
cannon of knowledge at the same time as
Kathy was saying I think what we can see
I mean one of the one of the levers that
I think the study of Asian Americans
gives us is how Asians Asian Americans
have always been central actors in
mediating racial formation and racial
colonial relations that is the figure of
the asian-american destabilizes white
non-white settler migrant developed
underdeveloped and these are these are
binaries that designate power that the
Asian is always the intermediary term
for so there's a way in which we could
we could delve into the history of Asian
Americans to only look at the history of
Asian Americans or we could follow the
history of Asian Americans to see how it
opens out into
worrying about modernity right
Asians moving around to build the
railroads is a story of modernity after
the moving a rat forcible capture and
moving around of African slaves it's a
it's a very particular episode of again
the building of American industrial
capitalism so I would just piggyback my
friend Kathy by saying that there's a
lot to learn about Asians being
instrumentalized
as the intermediary racial position in
order to stabilize a social order that
prizes whiteness and that doesn't so the
questions one of the challenges is how
to mobilize the study of asian-americans
in a way that it doesn't aspire to
assimilate to whiteness describing or
doesn't to speak institutionally doesn't
aspire to be another unit in the social
reproduction of the same but is actually
guided by these principles of
transformation and interrogating how we
know what we know and how we communicate
that to others so I think there's a lot
of potential but maybe it won't be
called Asian American Studies maybe it
will be the history of everything so for
the last question I'm gonna modify just
a little bit and before we open it up
because I think that the call you've
each made for us to rethink the
paradigms through which Asian American
cities have been assimilated into the
institution the alternative is not just
something abstract it actually lives in
your respective scholarship right it's
not altogether something that's a
waiting to be realized and produced so
just for the last round could you draw
from some of your recent work and talk a
little bit about how in your own
scholarship you try to instantiate these
commitments to gesture toward what might
now
be if that makes sense mm-hmm
I thank my colleagues for giving
sobering answers I'm a bit overblown in
comparison I feel a little embarrassed I
don't really know how to I don't even
know what you said Dan or what my [ __ ]
up
but I think suggestive was my latest
book third well studies I think what my
colleagues importantly said was that the
subject position of asian-americans has
every importance to say about so-called
bigger social processes ideas and so
forth and I think that's absolutely
correct and I think if I were to trace
my intellectual lineage I think that's
what happened one was moving from
California the comfort of California or
the relative comfort of California in
asian-american studies to the East Coast
and the discomfort and visioned here
where I had to defend asian-american
studies not so much in terms of the
demography of the state but the absence
of Asians like why do we need agen
bodies to speak about Asian American
Studies are the significance of it
anyway so I've sort of spun off and
moved off onto other worlds that's just
kind of crazy I guess but but what I
come back to is I think it's that is the
subject matters of Asian American
Studies and African history in my case
provided me with a platform to move to
move yeah and I think that that's
a luxury that many of my own peers do
not have in their institutional homes in
their identifications of their subject
matters and so forth so I must admit
that I am spoiled in that regard that is
I had the luxury to be crazy and just
move in any direction that I wanted I
confessed that but I still think that
the original fire of African history and
Asian American Studies indeed all of
ethnic studies are third-world studies
what I call now is the guiding light and
that is the ideas of liberation you know
not so much self-determination because I
think self-determination is grounded
within that humanist concept of the self
when I think of determination we need to
think more collectively as well as
individually but I'm just rambling am I
not yeah so I think I don't know you
know like if we can invent a new
language that's not bound by the Masters
language that we can sort of conceive of
theories of practice theories of
practice that would enable us to
transcend the kinds of confining spaces
that we are gifted with within the
Western tradition but also through our
own complicity in hegemony I think if we
can only sort of move past in some way
while deconstructing that and rejecting
the that legacy that binds us
to conceive of a new language and new
theory and new action and new places new
worlds entirely if we can sort of
achieve some measure of that I think we
will have achieved a great deal
especially given the kind of not just
hatred and animus it's really a kind of
disgusting booth I guess you know that
is the currency of our age it is really
very sad but I think what is hopeful is
our abilities our agency our power to
inspire and to conceive of new worlds
yeah so I I know that your recent yeah
like recent projects so I actually never
thought I would be the person putting
together a lot of edited collections
right so but it happened it happened my
signature yeah and so if you email me
it's just a hashtag humblebrag so you're
gonna have to if you print out my email
it's 12 pages of every collection that
I've done so so thank you Lisa for
pointing that out
appreciate it mister but I think that
like you know for me and it like in
terms of recent work so like I I want to
provide a different perspective from the
last question because on the one hand
I'm very critical of the field right but
then on the other hand it it's also a
field that saved me and it saved me
intellectually it saved me in other ways
so in order to understand like why I'm
drawn to doing these types of
collections it's important I think for
me and not for anybody else but for me
to kind of go back to my first job which
was not at the University of Connecticut
it was actually at Penn State Erie and I
usually say where dreams die right so it
was my first job and unfortunately I
think as of one of two Asian Americans
in the city of Erie I lived on Japan
Street I I didn't have a shovel I just
had a little garden like Spade and when
the lake-effect snow went out you know
came I was just out there I fell into a
snowbank and I was just hoping my tears
would melt through the salt and I know
that people thought oh she's just a
really naive emigrate like so so I know
that but um when I was in Penn State
when I was at Penn State Erie I was not
only the the single person who did
ancient American Studies I was the only
faculty member of color in what was
deemed the College of Liberal Arts and
Social Sciences right so imagine like
that level of isolation and it was
really trying to find a way to
articulate Asian American Studies when
you did not have the benefit of
colleagues when you didn't have the
benefit of even a library and what I
found was that you know there was
actually something missing within the
field in terms of affordable works that
would provide students with a scholarly
genealogy in a way that was kind of
accessible in an undergraduate classroom
so that's actually one reason why I
pursued these collections I also believe
in affordability of textbooks and you
know one of the things that really
struck me is that there are so many
wonderful monographs out there but you
know in terms of the scholarship that
we're producing we're not really giving
much of an entry point to those who are
new to the field right instead when I
would read a lot of monographs I would
think I'm in the middle of a discussion
and it's a wonderful discussion but I
don't know where the field has been nor
do I know where it's going right so
that's actually kind of why animated me
to do this but I was really struck by
like something that Gary said in terms
of just like kind of the contemporary
moment right so and I want to kind of
conclude with flash points for Asian
American Studies so that was actually a
project born out of my my egotistical
frustration that nobody would ever call
me as the Association president when
there was a scandal or a controversy
affecting asian-americans right and not
that I would be called I mean like you
know the only call I got was about the
like the Oscars when Chris Rock had
brought out Asia and Asian American
children and I was asked to respond
whether or not I thought it was funny
and one thing that really struck me was
that there are so many wonderful and
amazing scholars in our field and yet
none of them are asked to do public
facing like you know kind of scholarship
in that way rather there are other
people who are race theorists there are
other people who can talk about
whiteness even when we get to something
like what's happening at Harvard very
rarely will you see an asian-american
esteem context it's usually somebody who
and rightfully is an activist but
there's not that like kind of sense that
Americanists have anything to add to the
conversation and that was actually
something that really struck me and I
kind of asked people to contribute to
flashpoints on that notion which is how
is the work that you're doing relevant
not only to a narrow field of inquiry
but also relevant in terms of a global
imaginary and also contemporary domestic
issues so when I conceptualize
flashpoints this was 2015 and then you
know I was going along and then Trump
got elected right and and to me that was
a very difficult moment because in some
ways it was a moment where everything
that had been included in the collection
which engaged critical university
studies like the presence of Chinese
students on campuses transpacific you
know entanglements militarization Lisa
had co-authored a piece with Ehnle
espíritu and Lisa honey ama Jeremy Lin
and the fact that nobody asked you
should Americans to comment etc etc you
know one of the things that really
struck me was that the relevance of the
collection did not need to be shown
after Trump because now the mask had
been you know ripped and we no longer
had to talk about colorblind
multiculturalism right we could actually
start having a real conversation about
white supremacy so so that was actually
what Anna made at that project and I'm
currently working on a special issue of
Journal of Asian American Studies with
both of these individuals included to
talk about the state of field for that
very reason and there's one person who
still owes me
[Music]
[Laughter]
as you mentioned the public intellectual
of a public-facing asian-american
scholar I just I wanted to just give a
shout out to Jenelle Wong and where's
Jennifer Lee's work and Kartik Roman
often I think they they've been really
great about getting statistics that
showed that Asian Americans have
historically been for affirmative action
and have benefited from affirmative
action that they don't want to be used
as a wedge and this Edward Blum lawsuit
which i think is really really helpful
and maybe because of being forced into
the light they were equipped little
stats which is really great yeah but my
question is about my recent book
intimacy's of four continents and how it
articulates to Asian American Studies
and the field and so this I think just
picking up on what I was saying before
about Asians being this mediating term
but also Asia being a mediating location
and Asian labor being a mediated labor
force between free and unfree labor
[Music]
intimacy's of four continents is trying
to ask how asia and asians put into
relief formerly inaccessible connections
between different histories that are
normally studied separately I think we
hopefully all feel in solidarity in a
kind of straightforward way with other
struggles other groups of color and and
other social movements but I think one
of the things that was motivating me and
writing the intimacy's of four
continents was to see how these
connections occurred in history how the
abolition of slavery was very connected
to the introduction of Asian migrant
labor but then all
so to see how history and historical
narratives forget those connections so
or how settler colonialism historical
and ongoing settler colonialism and
dispossession of indigenous people goes
hand-in-hand but differs from slavery
you couldn't have slavery without
settler colonialism so rather than a
kind of simple equivalence between
different disenfranchised or
historically oppressed groups I was
interested in seeing how these
connections occur and how the archive
compartmentalizes the different
struggles and makes their connections
obscure because if the connections are
obscure in the past then they're going
to be more difficult to reconstruct in
the present and unfortunately it's not
that you couldn't reconstruct
connections based on equivalence but it
it conforms unfortunately with liberal
identity politics and interest politics
and I think when you begin to try to
motivate people in relationship to their
own groups interests then you get into
this problem of you know everybody
wanting a slice of a pie as opposed to
seeing that these these disparate these
apparently disparate histories are
actually quite interlocked and are part
of this multiple differentiated unity of
global history or global capitalist
history or racial capitalists history so
so in a way I was interested in seeing
how there were connections between
settler colonialism in the Americas and
the transatlantic slave trade the
emergence of European liberalism and the
East Indies and China trades and you
know I suppose the stakes of that are
seeing how in the present the
stereotyping of Asians the the
denigration of Asians as either Yellow
Peril
or
minority is absolutely connected with
anti-blackness is absolutely connected
with his llama phobia that they're part
of the same yeah so even though it's a
quite archival and historical study I
think those are my stakes is to see a
comparative relational history that's
been obscured that also because we know
it's been obscured would motivate us to
to to dig into why particular kinds of
knowledge is concealed and other kinds
of knowledge revealed and also it's very
much a book about liberalism and the
ways in which liberal guarantees which
connects with our current events with
the you know the disillusionment with
this charade that we've just been
witnessing you know I think it the
history of Asian Americans the history
of liberalism with respect to
colonialism and its imprecation and
colonial rule and extraction you know or
even if we just look at the US history
of you know Dred Scott Plessy versus
Ferguson we know that the courts are not
always the guarantors of freedom and
social justice so we can't rely on them
to be that and so if we think about the
history of Asian Americans but also
history of Native Americans African
Americans and others I think that it's
not that we don't wish that the the
Democratic promise would be fulfilled
but we have enough history behind us to
know that we can't count on it so rich
and illuminating we have a little bit of
time for questions and I'd love to have
you engaged the panelists now with some
of your thoughts inquiries
thank you hi my name is Catherine I'm a
sophomore L College I just have a
question for you guys regarding like
Asian American Studies as you know a
program at places like Stanford but the
lack of it here at Yale and like having
something like ethnicity race and
migration instead I'm wondering like in
your experience what you find to be not
like better but like the differences
between the two and what you would like
to see in the future of like
institutional change for like either
more Asian American Studies programs or
like more Asian American Studies classes
being offered under things like
ethnicity race and migration how you see
that changing and how you think like
what you think would be best for
students and faculty moving forward I
can talk about my past experience so I
taught at the University of California
for 20 years where there is as you
probably know a lot of Asian American
students so there was an absence of
curriculum but not an absence of student
body and as Kathy has well I guess I
would let me step back and say that I
think institution by institution and
region by region it differs and there
are different strategies to address
absences so in one place that might be
very important to have Asian and Asian
American Studies in order to have
faculty and to have courses offered at
UC San Diego we opted for a comparative
ethnic studies model that was
international and comparative in order
because there was so much in order to
teach Asian American courses but also to
teach the history of Asian Americans in
relationship to other histories and to
not separate it out into a distinct
field because there were so many
asian-americans there we felt there was
a danger
of segregating the study when it could
richly connect with someone else so I
think the demographics the historical
moment the institutional specificity
makes a lot of difference well I I don't
teach here but I it a place in the state
so so I I do want to actually explain
why you know I never thought I would be
part of a program that was Asian and
Asian American Studies right you know
because we always think of Asian Studies
as diametrically opposed to Asian
American Studies because of the Cold War
formation right like so but at the
University of Connecticut what's really
interesting is the University of
Connecticut
unlike Yale never had an Asian Studies
department right and in fact like one of
the things that it prides itself most on
is the fact that there's a Human Rights
Institute right and but at the
University of Connecticut Human Rights
is considered and this goes against
Gary's rightful observation but Human
Rights is cast as something that is
international where civil rights is what
happens domestically and I've always
really struggled with that because Human
Rights becomes an endeavour out there
and it becomes very much a colonial
project whereas like you know the work
here you know is stunning and there's a
one of my colleagues asked how I felt
about human rights in my own backyard
and I didn't know what that meant you
know because I kind of think about human
rights and rights violation is something
that is not necessarily bound by the
state okay so but when I got to the
University of Connecticut in 2007 based
on the story that I shared you probably
can guess I was so overjoyed right like
I was going I've won my liberation from
Erie Pennsylvania and I got to the
University of Connecticut where there
were only three jointly appointed
faculty in Asian American Studies I was
one of them and the program was about to
be sunsetted which is a nice
administrative term for shutting it down
and the reason why was going to be
sunset it was because the administration
stated there's no need for this program
you know it's not doing enough in terms
of education abroad and there's really
not the number of courses being taught
right you know so as a junior faculty
member the second year I took it over
and which was not an advisable move but
I really cared about Asian American
Studies this was actually what brought
me to Connecticut and the strategy that
I used was very well strategic right you
know great sentence I just put it for it
in so far is that I actually knew that
for the University of Connecticut Asian
Studies was much more legible and it was
elusive because they had never had it so
what I did was I actually stressed the
very international and global dimensions
of Asian American Studies from the
outset and I said this is very relevant
and we could talk specifically about
militarization rights violation etc so I
actually looked at the academic plan so
what we did was we grew from three
faculty to 13 tenure-track faculty
within the span of four years and we
also grew our affiliates from like seven
to 62 now right hashtag humble brag
right you know but but it was very
strategic because in order for us to
grow we had to engage Asian Studies but
we were able to do it on our own terms
so the faculty within the the department
or the program they're not doing the
traditional Asian Studies you know kind
of pre modernity discourse what they're
engaging our diasporas for example in
China but or like inner inner sections
between the Soviet Union and China yeah
like those were the types of hires that
we were able to do but I think that
Lisa's point is very very well taken I
don't think that like one model fits and
that's been the problem in terms of
these discussions about
institutionalization that's why Gary
goes everywhere
[Laughter]
well you know thank you okay if one more
question time for Chris hi my name is
Arianna and I'm a senior in Yale College
thank you all for this incredible panel
and I'm about to butcher the question
that I'm gonna ask but I'll try my best
so to the point that you talked about
with asian-americans proximal proximity
to whiteness but also to the point of
asian-american studies origins in kind
of populism and in a kind of personal
desire to understand your own histories
how do you think we can reconcile the
kind of politics that studying
asian-american history and literature
and culture drives us towards which is
like a kind of global anti capitalism
and anti-imperialism versus the kind of
politics that is actually practiced by
Asian Americans who live in the country
and you know who probably may not
necessarily see the necessity of forming
these kinds of coalition's so like for
example like how to reconcile Asian
American material success under
capitalism with the the logical
conclusion in some ways of Asian
American Studies leading to a revolution
against capitalism if that makes sense
would you like to say well I think this
is I mean you've put your finger on one
I mean if one of dance questions for us
was what are the challenges for the
future I think this is the challenge not
only for Asian American Studies for all
students in a sense I mean I think the
the indoctrination to aspire and to
achieve is a very strong Drive and
necessity and it's very hard to
understand that simultaneously with
critical thinking and I think Asian
Americans can do that just like everyone
else can but it's it but the part the
one part of your question I did want to
say is one of the things that that
Gary's books have demonstrated in his
own commitments have demonstrated is
that there have been lots of Asian
Americans dedicated to anti-imperialism
and anti-capitalism it isn't that I mean
maybe the view of a particular set of
young people that you're seeing seems
like they are enjoying material success
but I think there that you know there
are many many working Asian Americans
you know for who have been in the US for
quite a long time who are very organized
in applying their energies for a better
workplace conditions and less
segregation and so forth
her question was about what do you do
when there are actually Asian Americans
who want to assimilate and really is
that what you're talking about yeah that
doesn't excuse us the history of
racialization and internment okay and be
coming from sites in which the US has
been involved in Imperial War agent
Americans should know better I believe
in education there is power in education
and by education I don't mean a
propaganda school but I mean I think
that people and people can benefit from
a critical consciousness it would be
really important for all of us to you to
have that and to encourage that kind of
consciousness in all of us I'm not
talking about students or faculty and
talking about everyone and that yeah one
more question okay all right thank you
so much this is on anything limb from
Dartmouth College thank you so much for
this panel it um I learned so much from
it and I'm particularly interested in
the the liberal politics and interest
groups and interest politics that Lisa
was talking about and the way in which
we might think of the constellation and
consortium model of solidarity studies
as opposed to something that seems to
cohere around Asian American Studies
which from the way that the panel is
were thinking about it suggests that
there is a constellation of genealogies
of histories methods biographies that do
not go here in anything that we might
call Asian American Studies and then we
have to think about the radical
potential of something called Asian
American Asian American is critique in a
different way and how might we renew
that radicality so that it could
redefine the kinds of conversations that
we are all invested in but then to think
about the Asian as the intermediary
figure in the present moment in across
the IV's where we where there's the no
representation of Asian American Studies
and I know that a lot of students across
the IV's including my campus have been
so invested in something called Asian
American Studies and have been
organizing so passionately on behalf of
this of this field to try and create you
know something that might be
institutionalized as a form of study and
in the absence of content and I'm the
only senior agent Asian American scholar
it becomes really hard to think to
address these other questions to
students who are so deprived of
representation the same way that the
kinds of frenzy around crazy rich Asians
is about the kind of lack of
representation and people see that as a
moment of representation so so I'm very
drawn to this to this morning I been
secretly talking to to Lisa in my
various attempts to propose different
ways of thinking about asian-american
Studies at Dartmouth and we have gone
through so many different waves and the
liberal politics and interest group
groups on campus afford certain kinds of
recognizability around asian-american
essay formation so that you have to use
the vocabulary that's already there in
order for administrative kind of logics
to attend to those kinds of interests so
so it's a kind of double bind in some
ways because you have to want on the one
hand show that you are addressing
student interest because they want that
particular formation at the same time
you want to create something like trans
hemispheric decolonial and trans-pacific
kind of models for thinking about racial
capitalism about any number of in issues
that that this whole Center is doing so
so so how do we do that it's part of the
question right how do we how do we
create a space where it is possible to
do both and to advance the the student
interest when there is a lack thereof
but at the same time
yeah maybe a a big question but a minute
or so interests you and it has your
locality but what I would say is that
what Kathy's example demonstrates and
also the Yale example is another
demonstration is that you there are ways
to innovate and Ally with existing
formations in ways that might maximize
the potential of maintaining a critical
questioning of the very category so you
both want to make certain coursework
available and give that viz needed
much-needed visibility but sometimes
institutionalizing it isn't as a unit
brings other kinds of pitfalls so I'll
just be very quick it's a it's a
ginormous wonderfully important question
but one of the things that I would push
and this may make me sound like a
Philistine or an outlander is that
there's a tendency to kind of talk about
academic crises in terms of the
humanities or ethnic studies but what we
very rarely do is actually talk to
people in the sciences who are also
dealing with questions of
interdisciplinarity and new formations
and what I found is that when I talk to
my colleagues in genomics their
arguments and their concerns in turn in
terms of faculty lines joint
appointments in curriculum are identical
to the ones that I have as an
asian-american history and by talking to
those individuals those are the
individuals who are actually going to
make more legible the project of
solidarity studies or ethnic studies or
asian-american studies to Provost's and
other entities right you know so and
it's surprising because once you open up
that conversation you can't stop it and
it's awkward but but it's productive
gary has to bring us home yeah I'm hard
of hearing that's why I'm sorry yeah
okay final thought no okay all right
I just before we thank the panelists I
want to say I mean the opportunity to be
around a conversation like this where
there's a kind of like a searching
honesty that's not burdened by a kind of
cynicism there's still hope and
possibility is I really appreciate yeah
yeah yeah and and that there's a long
tradition of doing and thinking in those
ways that we can turn to so I just join
me once again in thanking this amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]